i wanna i wanna pull up this story real
quick um
this is from the bbc biden said quote
people will pay for horseback charge on
migrants at border so i'm sure you heard
the fake news
that the guy the border patrol guys were
riding the horses and the photos came
out and the left democrats were like
they're whips
so then what happened is the blind
administration is like okay you can't
use horses anymore and now biden's
saying they're going to pay the reason i
bring this up is you're just talking
about how
you know once once the left came in all
of a sudden they were much more in favor
or at least yeah you know it's like
so the
the current president down there said
hugs not bullets that was his whole
counter that's that was his whole
security policy for the cartels so
whether what you know for for the us
whether it's intentional or not you have
joe biden now
based on fake news condemning the border
patrol guys
it's just continually weakening our
security
it's erasing it just knowing some of the
people that were there because i i know
some of those people that were there a
lot of them were latinos a lot of them
were actually mexican uh second
generation third generation mexican
people uh they're riding around in
horses and they're utilizing the strap
of the have you ever ridden a horse
they're not they don't have crops of
whip they don't have a weapon
the rains that's what you see
they are completely undermanned under
supported and they're trying to do a job
which is stopping people from crossing
the border illegally and also
i mean there
i saw
somebody go down there trying to make it
about race um of course and uh
just seeing so
the us and again this this from my
experience training law enforcement here
stateside just went through the whole
black lives matter
corrosion which is a corrosion speaking
of somebody comes from a country where
police are not viewed well
this leads down a very dark path yeah
people don't want to be police officers
in the united states anymore
police academies have whole generations
that are just empty um there's places
where they don't have police you know
they can't pay them enough and or you
can't get paid enough to work in some of
these places
that leads to avoid
an authority and policing void in some
places
um what comes next
you know
mexico comes next you know uh the
corrosion
of uh of the small rules getting set to
the side small rules get set to the side
you know you can walk into a
you know a target in california and just
fill a bag full of stuff and just walk
out no problem as long as it doesn't
pass
you know small rules and i'm from
tijuana
you know it's not
it's not it's not a it's not a first
world place
but i go to la and i want to wash my
wash my hands afterwards right it's
amazing to see how it's
slowly shifting the corrosion that's
come
in this country as far as being against
law enforcement again not all law
enforcement is okay there's a bad people
in law enforcement there's bad horrible
people not for them in
there's four there's people that did
horrible things here in the states
there's people that are corrupt they're
working for law enforcement people that
shouldn't be working for law enforcement
here stateside that have a
completely bad mindset as part of what
they're doing
but what comes if you don't have a
police force
you know
like i was in port i was in the portland
riots day 101 of the portland riots i
went out there oh wow people feel like
you're going to be out there yeah what
do you want to do what do you want to
see i always want to go to the weird
places so i went to the riots
uh two percent cs gas was being utilized
against the protesters
which is basically pepper yeah and
something you put on your steak
there was a snack cart going through the
protest line which is pretty amazing
there was a little asian uh
girl with a bicycle helmet shouting you
know
kill the police or something like that
and then somebody threw a molotov uh at
the police and then landed on the feet
of a protester there who do you think
all of them screamed for when that
happened of course and the you know the
state police walked over put him out and
went back through the line you want to
know what would happen if there were no
police
i'll tell you
if something like portland happened
in a place where there were no police
the locals would walk out with their
guns and it would not be pretty see the
issue is in places like portland where
you do have the right to keep and bear
arms more so than many other states
regular people know
if antifa shows up with molotov
cocktails and i defend myself i go to
prison so they don't do it it's because
they're scared of the police and the
police allow ante for free reign yeah
so i'm not i've not been a big fan of
you know the police over that
specifically and over the lockdown stuff
and a lot of people have said oh you
can't blame the cops you got to blame
the leadership and i'm like no i think
if the cop walked up to the guy and
arrested him and said you deal with it
later at the very least you know that
would slowly start putting a stop to
these things if they started actively
you know going where these rioters were
going when they go into residential
neighborhoods and stopping them from
going to people's homes and threatening
the residents i was doing it though i
was there for a night and i i'm not the
you know the smartest you know man alive
or anything like that but i was there
for a night and i could figure out that
all these people there were not from
portland that they were all bust in and
or drove in and all
carpooled in i could tell you exactly
where they parked i could tell you where
their plates were from i could tell you
where they were car surfing i would tell
you
just by walking around there and hearing
their conversations i could tell you
what social media they were utilizing to
organize their endeavors and it was all
a show it was all a played out show look
at the mccloskeys
right you can criticize them for waving
the guns around or whatever but the
point is a a group of black lives matter
people
broke into private property
and when they simply brandished their
weapons on their own property as people
were on their property and said get out
they got arrested and charged for it
yeah so regular people know this
anti-fog it's free rain black lives
matter gets free reign you can't defend
yourself
remove the police
people start defending themselves the
riots are over instantly people it would
not be it would not look good and i
would not want to see what happens but i
tell you if the cops won't actually
enforce this if the justice department
if the justice system will not hold
these people to account
eventually the police aren't losing
support we start seeing things like we
did where where trump supporters and
conservatives were throwing the blue
lives matter flag on the ground and
stomping on it yeah and then eventually
they're like i don't care get rid of the
cops whatever so be it if you're not
gonna protect me you're gonna ignore
what they do and then come at me when i
try to protect myself like we've seen in
the press numerous times
people are going to say no to it it's a
small one they're paying attention it's
the small rules that go first and then
the big ones start getting corroded and
i think we're past the small rules part
oh yeah it's it's insane and and again i
come from a country where that happened
probably in the 80s and the 90s and this
is the this is what comes after you know
mad max level
the fact and you see the haitian
migrants walking back and forth yeah
there's no border i'm sorry there's no
border you can't call it a board it's
not that's not correct it's it's not
there there's no border and also the
people that are enforcing the border on
this side are now even more neutered
that they were right so
you go into you know hypotheticals and
you know again if somebody like some
evil entity out there wanted to do
something on the border christmas right
now christmas
yeah this is christmas right now you
know uh
and also
who wants to go into border protection
you know that you know now like who
wants to go into any of these jobs
that guy with the reigns he's getting
being demonized by the president they
took their horses away right or fake
news biden is attacking them saying
they'll pay because
people on the democratic this is what
happens every single time this is why
look the democrats come out and say
hunter biden's laptop stories fake news
when it was real they come out and say
russia gate is real news when it's fake
ukraine gate is real news when it's fake
they say uh they're whipping people it's
fake news how often are we going to see
our culture our country capitulate to
the lies from these psychopaths who just
scream random garbage when they panic
yeah i mean the racism thing with a with
one of the most latin groups of federal
police out there is pretty insane uh
i don't get me wrong i i'm a migrant
like i'm a legal resident of this
country i went through my my my process
during trump's election which made my
process that usually takes six months
into one that took two years
and i'm not a fan and i was pretty
disappointed but i went through it
legally right i went through it legally
and
i'm an idiot
you know
i should have just you know just sat on
that borders crossed and get shipped out
to any you know whatever
i got i got i got friends i have a
friend in eastern europe and
it's actually a brutal conversation to
be like i would like my friend to simply
visit
simply visit you know two weeks come see
america for once damn near impossible
and then she's like should i just go to
mexico
and i was like well i can't you know
obviously
you're joking right
but that's the reality of like even
people in other countries are like
that's why you see people in africa fly
to brazil and come to mexico because
they know the border it doesn't exist
it's an open joke internationally that
you know it's it's a hard thing to get a
visa but it's easy just travel to mexico
yeah and it's not you don't so that you
don't even need a visa to go to mexico
you can just violently cross the
southern border into mexico be beat
federal police in mexico beat them up
cross the border violently just make it
all the way through go to the border and
be welcomed on the other side that
they'll fight so they'll fight the
police and in the southern border
they'll fight the police in the southern
border they'll throw rocks at them
they'll
they'll be violent towards them uh
they will go through communities and all
the communities are just doing this to
them
you know just go back yeah the pro there
was there were pro when the first
caravan uh cara migrant caravan came up
into tijuana
the locals protested
i remember that they make tijuana great
again hats which i may or may not have
something to do with that um
the the the the the locals made the were
wearing the the mayor of tijuana was
wearing a make tijuana great again right
but though
they were like called racist like all
these guys are brown right and also we
just absorbed a whole segment of the
population of the haitian migrants
coming into tijuana which they were i
mean as far as the the our experience
with them they were pretty good they
they melded into the populace they
worked they're fine now these uh
hondurans came in
and they were saying that they were
going to turn tijuana until honduras
right they were saying that they were
going to shoot people that they wanted
to mess with them you know two of them
got picked up by the cartels immediately
whoa
immediately so they calmed down a bit
and then they were complaining about the
food that they were being given
because
they didn't want beans
they thought that was pig food
which you see if you tell that to a
mexican
um
but you that's the experience that the
locals have had with them and it's not a
good experience and it's amazing that
you know the the first the camp they had
was next to a school they had to close
school down because they kept getting
harassed by the
by the people there
but the americans would come in
and hand out backpacks
tents food clothing
and these guys were like thank you
muchas gracias thank you thank you and
then you would see that at the opening
market being sold and flipped yep right
and it was like
is anybody seeing this
american media shows up get the kids out
let's put them around and the female's
out put them here on the on the
outskirts so they can get that's what
they need that way aoc can show up and
start crying at the fence tricking a
bunch of dumb people and devoting away
their rights and their in their
sovereignty the last the last caravan
that showed up in tijuana set up right
on the border and
right in the middle of it and i'll post
this picture up tonight i think i'll
find it right in the middle of that camp
biden flag
yeah
you know and yeah i went around and
talked to a few of them they were pretty
defensive
but main thing is that
doors open
welcome in this is the time the door's
going to close again probably in a few
years so we need to go now let us in joe
biden you said that in the 80s um is
when the little things started to become
overlooked and then it led slowly led
towards i mean mexico's have always been
the corruption's always been systemic
there but
yeah i mean the true corrosion that uh
you know that you know criminal
enterprises and been feeding the massive
drug market in the states and the
corruption that kind of produced in
mexico kind of started
growing and
how the corruption seeped into
uncorruptable organizations like the
military mexico had like
the military was like the uncorruptable
like these are these are last events
and then you had the zetas you know
and then you had a bunch of generals
being arrested for cartel ties and then
that shifted now that's why you see the
mexican marines being utilized more now
the u.s said well we don't use the
mexican military we're going to use the
mexican marines now that's what we saw
during the chapel raid
but now some of those guys have been
arrested guarding cartel guys you know
bodyguarding cartel guys uh
mysterious stuff happening in in certain
parts where they can they control the
ports i mean if they are incorruptable
and they are the leading defense in
mexico against the cartels why are voice
fentanyl flooding the country these guys
are in control of ports so
it's all for money
i mean yeah for them yeah i think i
think a big part of his money
i think a big part of it is lack of
opportunity i mean for somebody like me
growing up in tijuana
either it was going into work for a call
center going to work for a cartel or
going to work for the government
and
after coming out of working for the
government i can't tell you the
difference between working for a cartel
or a government down there as far as how
it was at the end color centers are
rough that's boring i mean
that's that's the opportunity you have
down there wow right
like i was in i was studying medicine
when 9 11 happened
and the economy just went in the toilet
down there after that because nobody
wanted to cross a border and have fun in
tijuana
anymore so
the only opportunity for me and a few of
my friends it's like when i grew up in
tijuana i was like a skater kid skated
the first time i did any lock picking
and stuff like that now i teach that and
stuff like that the first time i didn't
lock picking and stuff like i would
break into some
cartel house that had been abandoned and
we wanted to skate the pool
so that was my childhood
and it was fun it was it was it was
interesting tijuana was a pretty
interesting place
about a change a lot of my friends that
i grew up with went to work for the
cartels thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to see the full show come back
to this channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you